I had a panic attack when I turned in  the final draft of the book because  because I was I was worried about the  Judgment I was worried about the people  hated me saying oh you're a bad mom and  you know you're this and you're that I  remember going outside sitting down by  the fire to talk to my husband and  saying  I don't know what I did I I think I need  to pull the plug but he just turned to  me and he said  he said you belong to no one yeah and  it's sort of interesting to hear a  husband say that I thought it was  incredible what did that mean to you  gave me all the confidence to go forward  and just  be able to be vulnerable I actually got  it tattooed on my arm says you belong to  no one right here so I don't forget it